So
now we have Andrew Wiking
not English or maybe
because it is but at least it's
online from Spain
so I'm going into the
depths
of Bottwienig anti-Moscow and so on
because I've now seen this train
I really have to admit that I
really don't know anything about it, so insofar as
this is now based on
Rander speculation,
yes, underneath it was really to be taken, it could
be that
A2 is also threatened
if, for example, I play A3,
beat a jacket in the knight anyway,
nonsense,
yes, we are inventing the theory
I think I probably do
n't have time to discover them, so
if he now makes bishop BC knight
I'll do the two okay, he can
next to that two then I hope that
things like that okay come up differently,
he takes it away
like that, so what you have now  here for the
material if you have anything at all
I'll do this one first
maybe that makes sense if you
can open the long diagonal with off
he can't because four doesn't work
because C3 is hanging
so
maybe you can now
use it to draw C2 bishop
Since E4 is somehow
yes, I mean, I don't know any
exceptions, it's
probably good, it's probably no longer a
theoretical position, I
think I've
probably already done something
that doesn't exist somehow,
yes, the knight
really wants to go to E4, no,
but how to get it  you go there
H4 would also be an idea of ​​course
H4 G4 knight has two
but it's very slow everything ne
or Queen E4 really of
course we look here now we
can make five here somehow then that was
kind of stupid
but the idea would be to play H4 now without
him being able to answer
so now he can really do C5,
no, well, I have to, but here I have to
open up here if he does C5, then
this whole structure here is also
porous,
so for example a B5 hangs then
really no, so I do
G4 on C5 and then with it
Then I have to
take care of it somehow, okay, it goes back,
so
now take and take knight G5 and
thus G4 games
then maybe I have the idea of
taking G5 again with the knight or
knight D24 really then
at least it will be good on the field
He now has no other
option to put the king somewhere,
so now there are really knights that have
six or
or is that actually stupid, it
could probably also be stupid,
so
I'll do this again
and then I'll go in there. I mean, of
course, there are options like that
Sacrificing the jellyfish or something like that, but
I don't have
much of an opportunity to play differently anymore,
so I didn't
think a tower of six might be
an option, yes, well, he has, he has
five and stuff like that,
well, okay,
everything on
C4 now works  not yet, yeah,
okay, of course it's just a matter
of muddling around here and seeing if
something can be done because the king is a bit
shaky, but
objectively he simply has three pawns more,
yes, you don't have anything, not really
what you can go for here
I hope that he somehow loosens up the
things here a little bit when
he pulls
all the pawn stuff forward.
Then something will work,
so I really don't see it now.
The knight on the 5 is of course
very, very strong
than the six of us  It's been a damn exchange
but okay, of course he can
play like that
now he's going through with C2 or whatever, that
's a bit stupid, I
didn't see that before,
I guarantee that,
which of course doesn't help, yes, okay,
yes, it's obviously difficult to
get involved in something like that  and sometimes no
plan at all,
no idea how to do it, what was
wrong
was definitely a bit much
material then